cela me fait mais tellement bizarre de
vous parler de cette série depuis que
j'ai découvert que je suis sous le
charme
sincèrement pour moi il n'ya pas
meilleure série netflix
après ce sont les goûts les couleurs
mais une série qui traite de voyage dans
le temps de façon très poétique très
premier degré ben moi ça me fascine je
gardais cette passion pour moi mais
étant donné que la saison 3 arrive dans
deux semaines même pas mais il est grand
temps de parler de ce final ensemble
afin d'avoir des potentiels réponse
puis toute façon je suis sûr qu on en
reparlera une fois la saison 3 sorties
bref sincèrement dites moi vos théories
en commentaire je suis très curieux de
vous lire à ce propos puis évidemment
n'hésite pas à laisser un pouce bleus si
toi aussi tu regarde la vidéo en 2052 en
vrai vous connaissez la chanson allez on
y va
je me dois de commencer par bart oscars
pour moi il est une clé depuis le début
déjà le truc avec bartos c'est qu'il
fait partie du groupe d'amis principal
tout en étant à moitié est séparée et
effectivement ce dernier a pactisé avec
noah et possède donc une machine à
voyager dans le temps qu'il se fera
dérobé dans la saison 2 de plus dans la
mise en scène si vous rappeler à la fin
de la saison 2 le yonath d'âge moyen qui
environ à une trentaine d'années a fait
et fait voyager francesca mag noces et
bartos pour éviter l'apocalypse est là
où ces méga intéressant c'est que nous
savons que adam qui est située en 1921
est accompagné de magnus et francesca en
beaucoup plus âgés adam est d'ailleurs
le plus vieux étant âgé de plus de 80
ans alors que mc noces et francesca
doivent avoir à peu près 50 60 ans donc
c'est un écart d'âge que l'on retrouve
exactement à la fin de la saison 2 avec
le yonath d'âge moyen et magnus et
francesca en jeunes donc voila vous
voyez parallèle mais qu'en est-il de
bartos ou est il là dedans
les créateurs de la série ont affirmé
que dans la conception
il y avait des éléments de la saison 3
qui avait été placé en saison 2 bref des
scènes censées arriver après qu'ils ont
finalement été mise avant pour une
meilleure conception de l'histoire en
cours alors moi avec tous ces indices et
si on relie tout ça on arrive à ce
personnage apparaissant dans la première
scène de la saison 2 dans l'épisode 1
beaucoup ont déjà penser pareil ce
personnage ressemble énormément à bartos
et nous sommes en 1921
là où se trouve également au mague noces
francesca et yonath en adam de plus dans
la conception de dark tout est bouclé
comme par exemple charles au tai chi et
la mère d'elisabeth et qui inversement
elisabeth et la mère de charlotte c'est
un paradoxe dit de boost rap comme pour
l'histoire du livre bref ici nous
aurions exactement la même chose puisque
nos arcueil bartos quand il est jeune et
l'influencent lui enseigne des choses et
inversement avec cette scène où bartos
lui dit se méfier dadame etc
la poésie est là mais pourquoi bartos
n'est pas aux côtés de adam comme pourra
l'être magnus ou francesca c'est ça qui
est interpellant et où je me dis qu'il
pourrait y avoir un rôle clé le truc
c'est qu'on ne sait pas vraiment qui est
bartos dans l'histoire alors que
pourtant il agit et voyage dans le temps
il a une relation particulière avec noah
et fait partie du cyclone douce créé à
tous est par exemple il est vrai qu'on
ne sait pas grand chose sur magnus mais
le personnage est un petit peu comme une
sorte de suiveurs il n'est pas acteur de
l'histoire c'est un personnage très
secondaire alors que bartos même s'il
est secondaire il ya vraiment du mystère
derrière et je suis sûr que justement on
en saura plus dans ce final
[Musique]
une règle fondamentale de dark et que
tout mais alors absolument tout des
relier ces mêmes d'ailleurs un sacré
casse tête et ce même un petit peu
effrayant en vrai je lave mes chaque
famille est vraiment lié par exemple ce
n'est pas officiel mais c'est plus de la
déduction va dire mais ce personnage
erna et possiblement l'ancêtre de plus
de la moitié des personnages de la série
je le répète ce n'est pas confirmé mais
elle serait la mère de noah pour
beaucoup de son vrai nom hanotaux beurre
ainsi que de sa soeur à gkn s nielsen
agnèse étant la mère de 30 t donc la
grand-mère d'hollerich et arrière grand
mère de ses enfants puis bah noah est
liée au doppler dont notamment charlotte
et et puis elisabeth
bref je ne vais pas les ans le détail
car on pourrait y passer des heures
tout ça pour vous dire qu'en fait quand
il ya un nouveau personnage dans la
série ou un personnage manquant on va
dire c'est qu'il ya toujours une
signification derrière et dans la série
nous sommes très loin de connaître tout
le monde déjà énorme point
d'interrogation pour moi mais qui est le
mari de claudia tiedemann et du coup le
père de regin à claudia est une actrice
principale dans les voyages dans le
temps donc comment une telle information
peut nous échapper
nous savons que cette dernière a grandi
aux côtés de 30 tonnes il scène le père
d'hollerich et qu'il y avait quelques
petits sentiments entre eux en
grandissant mais impossible de savoir si
c'est véritablement lui le père par
exemple d'arc tournant beaucoup autour
des secrets de famille
et des messes basses entre les habitants
de winneden bas il se pourrait que ce
soit un énorme secret de famille qui
n'ait jamais été révélés encore pour le
moment mais il se peut également que ces
dernières est été mariée à un voyageur
dans le temps étant donné que c'était
bien avant qu'elle soit elle même une
voyageuse temporel mais là où c'est très
bizarre c'est que la série d mentionne
jamais mais alors absolument jamais que
claudia aurait pu avoir un mari bas ce
qui est logique toute façon est un père
manquant pour regina il en parle jamais
tôt comme pour ehlg et doppler qui est
la mère de peter peter doppler une
information que l'on a jamais eu l gay a
été influencé toute sa vie par noah
il a même agi pour l'une ce dernier a
subi pas mal de traumatismes suite à son
agression par ulrich quand il était
enfant et l' influence de noah sur lui
donc compliqué de voir une gay avec une
femme fonder une famille et à tous les
coups soit il ya un énorme secret de
famille ma soi il ya un conflit temporel
là dedans
vu que l gay était comme un serviteur
pour noah il est possible que nos à lui
trouver quelqu'un de bien précis une
femme bien précises pour que justement
le cours des choses se suivent arrive et
caetera et qui deviennent le père de
peter et c est ce que vous voyez ce que
je veux dire
et c'est vraiment quelque chose de très
particulier car on voit jamais peter
quand il est enfant ou jeunes alors que
pourtant la famille doppler et très
implémenté dans winneden ils sont quand
même à l'origine de la centrale pour
continuer nous avons également l'arrivée
de hagneck nielsen en compagnie de son
fils 30 thé nielsen
alors on se doute bien que son arrivée
ce n'est pas vraiment géographique mais
surtout potentiellement temporel étant
donné qu'elle fait partie du sicm en
douce créé à tous est mais encore une
fois assez hardcore car cela veut dire
que 30 et n'est pas véritablement née
dans les années 40-50 mais beaucoup plus
tard ou avant on ne sait même pas mais
évidemment le truc ici c'est que on ne
connaît pas le mari d'agyness
nilsen est donc le père de 30000 scène
et enfin pour moi un point qui mérite
d'être soulevée ces l'horloger âgées
thanos alors évidemment pas celui avec
le gant de l'infini 1 et les pierres je
vous rassure tout de suite mais ce gala
s'est retrouvé avec charlotte qu'il a dû
élever quand il était plus jeune alors
qu'il n'a aucun lien de sang avec elle
charlotte issu d'une liaison un petit
peu particulière entre noah et elisabeth
ce personnage qui est l'horloger est
celui qui a monté la machine à voyager
sous les ordres de claudia et surtout on
ne sait pas d'où il sort il n'est relié
à personne à part pour ses connaissances
sur le temps connaissance faussé car
toutes ces dernières sont issus du
paradoxe de bootstrap soit que grâce à
lui les personnages du futur ont des
connaissances sur le temps mais que ses
personnages du futur vienne lui
apprendre avant qu'ils ne sachent vous
avez l'exemple avec le livre toute façon
ce personnage n'est qu'un outil en soit
par le biais de son livre et la
conception de la machine à voyager dans
le temps et par le biais du fait qu'il
est élevé charlotte
il est possible que en fait il soit
relié à nos a en fait vu que c'est lui
qui lui a amené certainement donc il est
tout à fait possible que leur relation
est beaucoup plus profonde que l'on
pourrait le penser pourquoi tadros pour
élever charlotte
bon recentrons nous sur du plus récent
avec le trailer
évidemment le poids important de la fin
de cette saison 2 c'est que la question
n'est plus vraiment quand mais plutôt ou
puisque la martha qui apparaît la fin et
qui emmène yonath avec elles semblent
provenir d'ailleurs ce qui est
intéressant ici pour moi dans le trailer
c'est que nous voyons justement cette
martha avec le ciré jaune de yonath
veste anorak tout ce que vous voulez
yonath et adam comme une sorte d'élu est
évidemment le premier
de par ce nom néanmoins adam ne va pas
sans sève et il est clair pour vous
comme pour moi que les éléments
principaux de l'intrigué sont quand même
yonath et marta il est tout à fait
possible que la martha qui est apparu à
la fin qui proviendrait d'une autre
dimension
soit dans le même cas que yonath les
dans sa dimension et donc elle symbolise
eve avec une aile en plus vieille qui
ferait de bordel et c'est quoi d'après
le trailer le fait de briser la boucle
serait le point final de la série
le but ultime nous voyons pas mal de
retour arrière dans le montage ou encore
des éléments d'intrigué en train de
brûler comme la lettre destinée à yonath
écrite par son père michael
cette lettre va dévoiler beaucoup de
choses aillent au nas est le fait de la
brûler permettrait qu'ils ne sachent pas
en gros et comme il est dit plusieurs
fois dans la série un simple petit grain
de sable peut tout chambouler
nous voyons également leur père d' adam
brûlé je pense que c'est exactement pour
les mêmes thématiques
mais là où je veux vous attirer dans ce
trailer c'est par rapport aux trois
nouveaux personnages
déjà qu'on soit clair ces personnages ne
forment qu'un seul et même personnage
c'est sûr à 100 % par rapport à la mise
en scène la ressemblance entre chacun
etc
on est sur quelqu'un qui s'est donc fait
oublier puisque en se déplaçant à 3 dans
le temps bah on ne l'a jamais vu dans la
série et techniquement mais au vu de
tout ce que je vous ai dit auparavant en
fonction de la règle de dark qui serait
t'il tout est lié dans dark toutes les
femmes y sont reliés et la ville n'est
pas bien grand
le problème c'est que l'on ne sait pas
si ce personnage provient de la réalité
de yonath ou de la martha que nous
voyons à la fin de la saison 2 alors
vous allez peut-être me trouvais fouet
mais ce personnage quand il est enfant
me fait penser à ma demie j'allais dire
ma demie quelle scène il me fait penser
à man's nilsen m'a dit un petit peu le
premier élément perturbateur dans la
série il est le premier enfant à
disparaître dans la série en 1986 les
disparitions s'ensuivront 2019
mais c'est véritablement lui le premier
à disparaître à cause de noah et l gay
donc en soi il pourrait être l'origine
le début et la fin et la fin et le début
yonath et tous les autres pensaient que
le début était le suicide de michael et
donc la disparition de michael mais
personne ne sait vraiment que miles à
voyager dans le temps en fait pour tous
il a juste disparu et voilà admettons
qu'il soit le magnat de la dimension de
martha bas ça pourrait totalement collet
puisque justement il ne serait pas mort
dans cette dimension
alors c'est une idée un petit peu
saugrenue j'en ai conscience c'est juste
un simple avis personnel car je trouve
que les deux enfants se ressemblent et
ça pourrait faire une bonne suite au
scénario et c'est justement un point
fort de la série où ils font bien
attention à prendre des acteurs qui se
ressemblent jeunes et vieux coin donc
voilà il faudra faire attention
néanmoins à cette cicatrice car je pense
sincèrement que c'est un détail
important bond pour conclure j'aimerais
vous montrer la photo du cycle windows
créé à tous est la photo révèle beaucoup
de choses sur la série il est possible
qu'on ait encore plus de réponses dessus
dans la saison 3 la vidéo déjà pas mal
longue et je n'ai pas vraiment de
réponse apportée là dessus mais il est
sûr d'une chose les personnes composant
le cyclone discret à tous est font
partie des gens qui ont conscience du
voyage dans le temps et donc des gens
faisant partie de windows
j'espère en tout cas vraiment que la
vidéo vous aura plu j'ai vraiment plus
que hâte de voir la fin de cette série
qui fait vraiment partie de mes préférés
sincèrement je crois que j'ai jamais
autant kiffé une série je vous remercie
de ouf les courageux de m'avoir gardé
jusque là franchement en espérant lire
votre avis dans les commentaires
comme toujours pour ceux qui veulent me
soutenir ce qui me fait vraiment chaud
au coeur d'ailleurs comme vous le savez
vous pouvez laisser un petit pouce bleus
et puis vous abonner à la chaîne vous
pouvez également regarder quelques
petites pub sur youtube c'est un petit
apport financier qui n'est vraiment pas
négligeable en vrai et vous pouvez
toujours rejoindre le discours si vous
le souhaitez et si vous voulez me parler
je vous encourage également à me suivre
sur twitter et puis instagram puis bah
merci d'être là quoi que le live art
soit avec vous c'était argot rock à les
laïcs site à regarder cette vidéo en
2050 de lol allez ciao
[Musique]